It's the 1940s.
The world is at war.
And for the first time in American history,...
...women are joining the full-time workforce in droves.
An organic chemist by the name of Hazel Bishop...
...is in the midst of designing aircraft fuel for different oil companies.
But her true interests lie elsewhere.
The influx of women in the workforce...
...hasn't changed the superficial expectations of society...
...and working women are expected to look well-groomed no matter their trade.
Bishop is sick of having to take time to powder her nose and reapply her lipstick.
Bishop spends her spare time working with stains and dyes,...
...mixing oils and experimenting with molten wax.
In a moment of vision and after years of hard work,...
...Bishop introduces one of the first smudge-proof,...
...long-lasting working woman's lipsticks that doesn't just tint the lips...
...but also keeps them healthy and moisturized.
Marketed as the only kissable lipstick, Bishop's product takes off.
And it isn't long before rival companies are not just replicating the lipstick...
...but creating other, more practical cosmetics.
Today, lip cosmetics are a billion-dollar industry.